hollywood investi dans le soufre
superproduction 3h20 pour raconter la
vie ou le mythe de l'un des héros
controversé rejeté de l'amérique noire
prénom mal comme non fixe plus du lmnp
extrémistes assassiné harlem en 305
c'est une bonne chose qu'il soit mort
par le coq noir ne s'étaient pas battus
pour nous nous les noirs on en serait
toujours au même point sur les trottoirs
de harlem on s'arrache ses casquettes
souvent sans connaître la signification
du xx xx choisi par malcom pour refuser
le nom d'esclaves de ses ancêtres il
luttait pour les droits civiques à la
même époque que martin luther king mais
bien peu savent ce qui les séparait
malcom x
ils se battaient martin luther king
était surtout un très chaud pendant que
le pasteur king prêche la non-violence
malcom x enseigne la colère le combat
pour l'intégration raciale ne mène nulle
part dit il
les blancs ne sont que des diables
décolorés il abandonnera plus tard son
discours extrémistes mais ses disciples
doivent toujours corriger son image
marqué par la violence
au lieu de dire tant dé la joue gauche
il disait si vous me frapper je
frapperai moi aussi c'est justice la loi
de la survie une loi normale après son
pèlerinage à la mecque
malcom x avait dit vouloir se joindre à
la lutte pour la conquête des droits
civiques en cessant de jouer le rôle
d'épouvantail qui avait été le sien
pendant près de 15 ans il devenait plus
crédible plus menaçant tant qu'il se
contentait d'agiter les foules tout
allait bien quand il s'est mis à parler
de paix tout est allé de travers et
c'est triste
harlem février 65
malcom x meurent ici 27 ans après sur la
porte de la salle où il fut assassiné un
écriteau la firme
il est toujours vivant
pour vous l'avez oublié avant qu
hollywood est un cinéaste noir spike lee
lui ai dit fit un mausolée en
cinémascope